like many people who have risen to Great
Fame in the business you were an NBC
page that's right you weren't right I
was not an NBC page no but Regis Philbin
Philbin
that's his name now sorry Philbin we
just felt a name that will live in
history Regis philbinen woman Regis
Philbin was an NBC page I believe but
you you were an NBC page I think when I
was doing late night you were an NBC
yeah you were you were and you know what
because you because okay the way I got
my sag card I don't know if you know the
story but the way I got my sad card is
because I was I think I either was a
page or I had just like left the program
but I kept my uniform which you're not
supposed to do and I convinced the guy
that shot the pilot for 30 Rock
um he like he directed A lot of the 30
Rock episodes they needed a page to do a
tour of your studio because we were they
were shooting on the floor of your
studio or something and I knew the yeah
I knew the speech I was like and welcome
the thing of Conan O'Brien and I would
make up stuff but I don't remember what
I said but because I knew the Spiel I
was like I just let me do it I was like
I can do it and then he threw threw me
in on camera and I did it and because I
had a line you know the SAG Union rules
if they had to give you a card no here's
okay this fascinates me because there
were pages that worked at 30 Rock
obviously in real life and they would um
do tours of my studio and I remembered
accidentally listening once to one of
the tours and everything they were
saying was not true yeah and this page
this one page that I was listening to
this was not you was saying that the
stars in the back painted on the wall
reflect uh are there because uh Conan
has long been a huge fan of astronomy
and I'm I'm I was like brushing my teeth
in the hall and I heard this and I went
what are they talking about okay no it's
late nights stars stars late at night
that's all it is and people in the crew
going and this person wasn't doing a bit
or anything that's just was a piece of
misinformation like a game of telephone
that had been passed on over nine
different page Generations someone talks
about this in her book that she when she
was a page and gave tour she was just
lying about stuff okay but there was a
game that the pages and this is like
whatever I don't know if they still do
this but there was a game that all the
pages would play where you would you
would go okay I'm going to give you
three words for your next tour and you
have to you have to incorporate these
words into your speech at some point it
has to be believable and the words were
always insane I mean maybe it was you
know it was like penguin or whatever and
then you'd be like and this studio is
cold because 10 years ago they had
Penguins on the show and they had to you
know raise the temperature and then they
just they never changed it or whatever
and that's real you did tell a tour
groups that I did say something about
penguins yeah because our studio was
cold and the reason it was kept cold is
because of all the lights in the ceiling
right so that once you get an audience
and you turn the lights on temperature
goes up like 15 degrees so you have to
keep it artificially cold so that it's
comfortable once the show is going yeah
but also so people don't fall asleep
not that they would not that they would
they lied to about they lied to me about
the lifetime that was just that's also
why they electrified the city
no no but number three three C is
falling asleep
no no I mean no one could if I were
performing yeah
well that was what I always heard about
Letterman is that he liked the studio
cold because it kept the audience on
their toes yeah
um I didn't want it to be warm but I
didn't necessarily want it to be cold
it's just I know good guy it's very cold
in here right now it is freezing in here
but that's for a whole different reason
we store government surplus Meats
yeah that's how we pay for everything
that's a side business of ours this is
like one of the most terrifying rooms
I've ever been in what are you talking
about is this weird dude like oh just
because there are pictures of me all
over the place with no shirt on this is
an audio thing you were in the forest
with child skulls I know I love anyone
who was like come to the forest you I
have a skull of a child wow this podcast
studio is creepy what a creepy place
I don't know it is not weird it's a
beautiful day budgets and stuff
um whatever so whatever
whatever you gotta do man whatever you
want I gotta do this so you lied on the
tour and told people things about me
that weren't true do we have any
interactions I don't know if we did no
no I would no I was way too too drunk to
to have the confidence to talk to
anybody it was uh I noticed when I first
was working at uh at my job at late
night people Pages would Scurry past me
and seem kind of nervous and I remember
talking to one once and they said I was
told not to make eye contact with you
yeah and I found out that that was a
holdover from like the past but I'm very
I need eye contact a little too much I
love chatting people up I'm constantly
chatting you're doing it right now
I love eye contact now and
um yeah there were a lot of things like
that I think that that's what made that
at least at the time that I was in and
that's what made the page program kind
of exciting because there was so many
holdover like weird yeah just like weird
things like that you would have to do or
know or and you felt kind of even if
yeah even if it was weird like that you
felt like well like part of something
you have to yeah but also I've noticed
that I don't know if you've noticed this
but once you became a known person
sometimes there are people that say
things on your behalf that oh yeah that
you don't even agree with yeah and you
find out later well we were told before
you came that uh there was to be no
mention of donuts because you know and
you're like what what are you talking
about and it was someone not playing a
prank but someone who was well
intentioned who misunderstood something
telling you telling people beforehand
and then you realize how much of this is
going on around me where people were
told whatever you do girl were you told
before you met me I was told to engage
in conversation about astronomy with you
that's why I gave you the job because
it's a fascination of mine that's why I
covered the studio really and we're in
like a [ __ ] spaceship right now it's
not a bunch of lasers
I was very charged and erotic